what an episode you guys are going to
watch
a real fun one at the end sal and i may
or may not have started an only fantasy
we started only fans uh we're gonna beat
bad baby you're gonna beat bad baby we
talk about puerto rico al roker yeah
baby it's a great woman with the longest
steps in the world the longest legs in
the world yeah we're gonna do only fans
uh we're not we're not showing holes but
we're showing everything else yeah and
we're gonna love it and um what i think
also you're gonna love sal back me up if
you'll love this is right now on netflix
i have a comedy special called special
if you have netflix it's there baby i
mean this is it go watch it this is and
it's hysterical thank you and i've seen
it and uh you're gonna love it and
that's huge that's huge and then um if
you want to see me live may 5th i am in
los angeles at the peppermint uh lounge
may uh 14th at count basie which is sold
out in red bank new jersey thank you
thank you may 24th vulcan gas company
austin texas at may 26 phoenix arizona
then i'm coming off the road for two
months all the merch is available right
now links are in the videos links are on
our social pages merch is finally out uh
if you go see him may 14th at the red
bank you can't see me me may 14 to the
beacon but it's sold out
so you can't do it anymore you know what
go see steve byrne go see somebody else
may 14th steve byrne yeah uh may 21st in
san diego may 22nd at the wilton in los
angeles and uh july 15th at the virgin
uh theater in in las vegas all fun stuff
enjoy the episode patreon coming soon
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to
[Music]
hey babe
it's a code word no matter where you say
it you know that you'll be heard hey
babe hey babe how you doing what's up
love the shirt coconuts yeah
you know i saw you putting on a printed
tee today look at that a printed button
down today and i said let me let me let
me throw one on and i want to shout out
the vibe the roosevelts uh the rsvlts
the uh kunu flex shirt this shirt most
comfortable shirt this is not even a
problem i mean they don't sponsor
anything i'm just genuinely telling you
this shirt is awesome yeah i got uh the
bears uh print on this one they got a
lot of great shirts out there um so yeah
man and speaking of coconuts um i was in
puerto rico oh you just got back you
were there for an extended amount of
time right babe you know my you know my
family i have family there but are you
kidding me that's what i said you were
in pr that's my half of my homeland we
knew it was the volcano yeah
yeah the diaz's
and
directly outside my hotel directly
outside my hotel room that a guy climbed
a tree and was with a machete me and my
family were watching this with the
machete and was hacking down
coconuts they told me if these coconuts
would have fallen they could kill any
member of your family from that height
from that height chopped it down with
them with the machete they left us the
coconut version of falling rocks exactly
yeah smash the coconut
they they said just smash it i smashed
the coconut was drinking real coconut
juice and ate the coconut meat right out
of a coconut was just in the tree it was
amazing it was some way to live huh oh
love it you're feeling one at one with
the yeah you were gonna you you decided
to go there on a vacation like you said
time out let's go yeah i said timeout
let's go on a vacation i was supposed to
actually do a show there i know i
plugged that for you yes and i cancelled
it uh which i appreciate i i canceled it
because i just when i was there i said
you know what it's a lot of stress to
think about doing standards
a lot stand up so stressful it's a
beautiful thing we both love that it's
our careers but it's very you got to
understand it's not just the show it's
thinking about the show all day every
second preparing and i just wanted to
relax i really wanted to just relax so i
canceled the show i apologize to the
fans that that uh may have bought
tickets i would love to go back there
just right now it's a bit much i just
haven't really taken a break at all i
know you have now march of 2020 yeah so
i was just like i don't want to uh i
just wanted to take a break and um how
was it
it was unbelievable you ready for this
tell me about your day okay how was the
food did you go to the beach how was the
water how'd the kids like it so
literally were there were there
vixens walking around they were victims
of puerto rican nature video vixens okay
they literally i had a hotel in my hotel
room there was a pool a plunge pool
right outside the room beautiful
we got there at let's say 2 pm
put my bags down part of pr
dorado sure by the way there i just want
to save foreign i literally have family
in dorado dorado's amazing there was a
really annoying woman on the plane
coming back she was like a full white
woman blonde hair blue eyes was speaking
like as english as a full white a full
white coming you know on the plane going
back from san juan back to new york she
goes the flight attendant comes over you
know is asking you know for um you know
would you want snacks drinks whatever
this woman is speaking like she doesn't
have a latino accent at all she goes
i'll take um yeah i'll take pretzels and
she goes do you have coca-cola
i hate that and i was like
why are you saying it like that she goes
do you have pretzels peanuts and
coca-cola
i was like oh i hate this lady so much i
had a friend once like a long time ago
go backpacking through europe and then
when when they came back they were using
all the like they had a little bit of a
like a european accent and were using
all the terms like oh i'm gonna go to
the loo i'm like you dude you're there
for six weeks
yeah do you want yeah um why don't we
why don't we get food but instead of
going to the restaurant let's get it for
take away it's like shut up it's
delivery
yeah you ever say anything to them how
do you even approach your friend and say
no i never did i just rolled my eyes in
the back yeah it's it's extremely
annoying yeah it's it's extremely
annoying i mean i get it you with a
couple of months you saw a lot of
cultures and stuff but you didn't change
what you're not
but so we literally i drop my bags
whatever it is two o'clock go to the
bathroom to whatever wash my face from
the flight my daughter immediately my
six-year-old daughter gets butt naked
puts on her uh bathing suit
i'm talking about we were i wasn't there
for 90 seconds
jumps into the plunge pool not realizing
his three foot pool scrapes her knees on
the bottom of the pool is gushing blood
in the water immediately
immediately as i'm running to go get my
six-year-old daughter out of the pool
screaming crying gushing blood because
the rest of my family was down by the
beach
my ten-month-old daughter is just
learning how to walk goes to take one
steps fall smashes her head off the
hotel
you know floor that has no carpets i
have two now both my doors are screaming
hysterical crying i'm holding one the
other one's bleeding in the pool and you
were like shows cancelled yeah and i was
like i can't do this shows cancer i need
to relax yeah and i a tt jerry who was
one of the co-hosts of hey babe is
climbing one of the trees to see if if
he can get a coconut he looks like a
chupacabra
i was calling him chupatiti
it was
that see that's the pool in the
background see that's my room you got
those coconut trees right there and
that's a pool right behind me the pool
belongs to the hotel of your room no
that's my
personal pool garage
and i never had one before um and it was
um and it was wild and i but honestly
that's how it started that's how the
vacation started um oh and my stepson
had a stomach virus but we just said me
and my family made a decision said we're
in puerto rico
let's get her some band-aids the babe
the little violet's head she'll be fine
nice and then tristan
take half of pepto yeah and that's it
and you know what we had the best time
we uh the ritz carlton dorado another
thing we're staying there i'm watching
the news the next morning i'm watching
the news still in my routine i throw on
the today show this is 1000 true this
can be verified okay channel 4. that's
where i go to today's show nbc
i go i'm watching the news peacock i see
al roker yeah i see al roker's doing the
weather from puerto rico no i said no
way no way
i gotta find them i gotta find them i
said i gotta go get myself a coca-cola
and i gotta find them i
hate you didn't find them you found al
roker in puerto rico i was in room 513
at the ritz carlton dorado yeah okay
literally sal hold my hand tell me not
to tell you
i come
i want to believe oh let's go i'm ready
my brother jasmine was there [ __ ] is
there tt jerry delilah violet even
though she had a concussion tristan even
though he's puking or as as god as my
witness
i walk out of room 513
no who's walking out of room 511
his son and wife no and you just saw him
do it in the news yes and then i see him
in i see him in the gym hours later i
didn't say he's at the gym he goes it
hits the gym all the time that guy was
in the gym every day at 7 30 in the
morning or uh 9 30 in the morning
because he was doing the news wow
i go see him at again hud there i don't
i the there were witnesses i don't know
who they are but they heard this i was
wearing a whitney houston shirt a purple
and usage shirt where she has a shaved
head in one of her and one of her album
covers he al roker i'm on the treadmill
i'll rockers on the elliptical i go to
al roker i say he goes i like that shirt
i go yeah i'm going to tell my kids it
was jaded pinkett smith
he goes he
goes yeah and i was like why did i say
that
like why why did i why and that's the
only interaction that's the only
interaction with al roker except and
you're ready for this we had ordered a
cabana we had oil he didn't even know
you're a comic you decided
yeah there's an encounter pool cabana
and then there's the the the capana by
positive i don't know what that pool was
called so you got a cabana in positive i
got in dorado i got the cambodia by
positive on
by the restaurant positivo uh in dorado
and i i said and they made a mistake
i was supposed to get the cabana for
wednesday i'm sorry for tuesday so we go
up show up to the cabana for tuesday
they don't have your rights we're ready
for the cabana they
they say oh i'm so sorry they said we
thought it was wednesday and i said no
tuesday they said oh we're so sorry
they go they go we thought it was for
wednesday i said we specifically said
tuesday they said well we unfortunately
all the the the the combination that was
for you we gave to mr al roker now
walker
[Laughter]
but al roker um also famously [ __ ] his
pants at the white house uh i should
have asked him about that but what now
can you take us through the story pip
because you've told me this multiple
times that he's pooped his pants at the
white house that's my favorite thing
so
uh he wrote a book a few years ago about
his struggles with weight loss sat down
with i've met rox you met alvaro
yeah maybe i was on set i think i was on
i did the today show yeah yeah i don't i
i know i've met him more than once i
think that functions you do the tonight
show no we we have to be fun to do that
tonight
we had
three cancellations of the tonight show
what are they cancelling for no we had
it was covent three times got it three
times and then we were supposed to go in
studio and
i was out of the country we should try
to get hey babe on a late night show
who's trying to get hay babe on the
tonight show that'd be fun i wonder if
we could do that why not seriously i
wonder if we could like use the k'nex
and be like can we get hey babe as it
gets like has it has you ever been a
guest of a podcast i don't think so i
mean like we have a podcast yeah why
don't we try we're we're a new york
podcast you know why don't we try to do
that you got a friendly podcast let's do
hey babe i like it yeah i like it we
could try it yeah i love that let's put
that out in the universe also i haven't
seen you guys since we went to vegas to
the wind where you performed and in
vegas something really weird happened at
the pool they actually hire hawks to
patrol the pool did you see that what
they hire hawks to patrol the wind pool
i swear to god i i asked the woman about
it she gets paid to walk around with her
hawk and the hawk like kills rodents
really that's a job
at the pool i don't think i went to the
pool at the win it's real now for not
speaking of vegas babe i am actually
playing the theater at the virgin hotel
on july 15th at the one hotel the virgin
hotel there's a new hotel oh the version
it's a new hard rock it's the oh wow the
old hard rock yeah
i'll be there july 15th tickets are on
sale actually right this second i forgot
to say last episode
i forgot to say virgin hotel seems great
now you're going to be doing something
in there
tonight
tonight oh
you got a hundred dollar bill put your
hands up
make noise all the ladies put your hands
up all the ladies make noise you got
real hair real fingernails if you got a
job and you go to school and you don't
even know about what that baby talk
about make some noise
there it is want an energy ball yeah i
think i need there you go that's what i
was missing nice
what does sal do in vegas what's your
vegas
what do i do yeah hold up in the goddamn
room oh yeah okay no you don't shop i
feel like you just no i shop like a
mother
let me shop them i go to the casino i
throw around some craps
pool love it
go in the pool
i was running you in vegas
[Music]
park park park and then but no but then
we went remember we went for your party
and we were on the lazy river together
oh we i thought you were going to when i
performed there you doing my god no i
never performed there with you oh yeah
we went to um
yeah
we're in the lazy river yeah it was fun
we got our own pool up to caesars yes
that was fun um i remember that so i own
jean concert but i think you left price
i left unfortunately he shared his pants
too right you said
apparently
the one we were at in vegas the yellow
brick road tour by the way three hours
of bangers
after every single song he got up went
to the front of stage and took a bow and
he got a standing ovation at every song
he played i think he played like 27
songs
and every single song he had a spittoon
next to him and he would just like and
just spit spit into this gold spittoon
wow
like he needed to spit i guess to clear
his voice whatever he just leaned over
and taka spit into the clear mountain
seriously in the gold splatoon and then
he would get up he would bow the whole
place would rise then he'd go like this
like almost like royalty and he'd sit
back down it came out and we talked
about this yeah we came out on the paper
later that he was pissing himself the
entire time on that one why just had to
go he said he wore a diaper and he was
just pissing let's just say he wore his
pajamas too for the last he might have
i don't understand i don't know if he
like needed to wear the diaper or if he
just like was like i think i'm gonna
take it easy i now know i now know in
hindsight if that if i if that
opportunity ever happened again which
wouldn't because you know he's retiring
now since elton john but that was that
moment was that was more important than
me doing a comedy show i should have
just done that for my life i wish that i
did a comedy show i flew southwest
airlines and did a comedy you know we
were on the road we were with a lot of
people folks we ended up going to that
concert with like 30 people wow yeah
that's like yesterday we had a whole
massive it wasn't even a suite it was a
cut out section of the arena right above
the stage it was open air it wasn't a
sweet but it was completely blocked off
and we had like it was an open suite but
we also had our own huge like tables
like it was it was like nothing i've
ever seen in vegas at the t-mobile arena
they have this section it's so you gotta
google it it's like you can have a
section of the arena it's wild it's wild
everybody just chipped in and got it it
was crazy dude
i love it man shout out t-mobile you're
you're a t-mobile customer i used to be
right i used to be after 23 years i
abandoned them and you would get free um
you would get free uh uh wi-fi on
flights yeah being tmo um i have a hack
about that i'll tell you later tell us
all fair um
but they puerto rico recharged i went to
wow would you put on a lot of sunblock
though what do you mean i don't see a
golden bronze coming in my face a little
bit
yeah i guess i put on too much sunblock
no you didn't put on too much
you're not supposed you should protect
your skin at all costs so pay for it
later on in life literally you'll end up
looking like kane tanaka next week
we went to we went to old san juan we
went to el morro one of the fourteen you
have to go to the fort now motto in san
juan i haven't been to puerto rico never
been puerto rico
bro it was amazing we go it was one of
the it's so parents have a honeymoon now
it's always windy there right they sell
kites off the side of the road it's
always windy jasmine who we're with you
know she goes
i just don't want to lose my hat and i
was like you're not going to lose your
hat like whatever has her hat on
whatever she had just bought this hat
love this hat
we go up to el morro it's very windy
she's holding the hat she's holding the
hat she goes
i go to her um i go oh like we haven't
taken a picture at all we hadn't taken
one picture at all the whole whole time
we were there and i say which i never
say i was like let's take a picture
together up here it's like beautiful up
here she goes okay she goes let's use
your phone i go to pull out my phone to
take the picture
she doesn't like the picture she's like
you know what let me use my phone she
goes to take her uh get her phone out of
her bag hat blows right into the
atlantic ocean
right away there's nobody covering it or
did you run for no no i just took a
picture with her with her hair pinned
down knotted down with hat head and then
just let it go no one for it no it's
fully that's where we're standing it's
fully blown to the oh my god that's
gorgeous yeah that's like something out
of freaking
game of thrones yeah then then dude we
went first of all my san juan i loved it
i mean it looks like it feels like miami
um
it was great they have a district there
right in old san juan in the heart of
all time it's called la berla google la
perla l-e-p it is like literally you
cannot go in there if you go in there
and you take a picture or video gang
members will kill you this is there's
one way in one way out it looks like
cinco terra yeah no there's a video of a
girl i think like a white girl getting
lost and they won't let her leave
because she's taking videos and it's
like a thing that went on instagram
she's like i'm in la pearl
they won't let me no no it's like it and
they the cab drivers even uh jasmine's
puerto rican families like do not go in
la perla do not go in la perla you
cannot go in there what's up with that
fully ran by the gangs uh or not gangs
whatever they're called they don't call
oh this guy went into la perla this
white guy went into la perla
oh maybe shit's changed
but you're not supposed to go inside
puerto rico you go yeah la perla if you
guys have been if you guys went into la
perla and made it out uh comment below
doesn't san juan mean with john
what does it mean
and puerto rico means rich port
i didn't understand the significance of
puerto rico until i went there like
everybody and they mama wanted puerto
rico in the ancient world spain fought
over it denmark england you know united
states eventually owns it because this
port is so vital because it's when
you're coming across europe like when
spain would be traveling across the
atlantic ocean and get to the new lands
you know like the you know the united
states you know north america whatever
it was you know being discovered at that
time they have to stop and puerto rico
was like the best port to stop recharge
whatever and that's where christopher
columbus landed there i see
1493 the first one yeah imagine landing
in a tropical area and be like yo this
is sick yeah and then you walk into and
then and then he did that and he he
named it san juan batista after after
saint john the bat after john the
baptist who i believe got beheaded
didn't john the baptist get beheaded uh
what did they have did they cruise him
upside down i forgot his origins see if
john the baptist got beheaded did john
the baptist get beheaded i i think he
i'm pretty sure he got beheaded
that's a great hip-hop the heading of
saint john the baptist they cut his head
clean up september 11th
2022. that's the original 911 what wait
they got it
just recently what does that even happen
yet
um
oh he publicly reproved herrod for
divorcing his first wife and unlawfully
taking a second wife he then ordered him
to be killed by beheading that i don't
want to be beheaded i got to be honest
with you is there a an artist right now
named john baptiste yeah
he's on the colbert show right well he
is he not a musician is it he's just one
medium he just won a grammy
does he have a head
uh as of right now
you know what i was thinking about doing
oh by the way
uh have you ever been to savannah
georgia yeah you have yeah i was there
the uh the day that trump got uh won the
election perfect place to be
what are you doing
now is there for my birthday and on
vacation i remember i went to bed and
woke up and then that night was the uh
election so i booked just a land
uh
in june i'm gonna go to savannah georgia
where should i go what should i do tell
me about savannah oh babe tell it
you are going to have savannah
because this is two days enough
historical it's two days enough two days
men i did three and three i split it up
i did i think i did three in savann's
and then i did a uh i and then i drove
uh after that to um
to uh charleston yes oh my god you did
back to back yeah commute yeah i did and
i did three days there and both are
littered they're lousy with history well
charleston i've been to yeah charleston
i've been to yeah um and i was insane
but you're saying
compare savannah to charleston are they
apples to oranges or they both have a
lot of historic stuff a lot of old old
school like uh like they have
historical districts that are really
beautiful you can do a lot of house
tours uh they're by the water both of
them um
i hate people that sip like this
yeah
very annoying yeah my mom does that
i know i don't like it when she does
that
sunday launch sunday losses you've been
seeing the commercials i've been seeing
commercials all over the place and now
they're uh they're advertising with us
here it's hard to imagine spring's
almost here everyone's getting their
lawns back into shape and you want that
beautiful lawn and sunday is basically a
subscription service that sends you
everything you need to take care of your
lawn so you don't have to worry about it
just comes right to the house uh
most most lawn
treatments use a lot of chemicals uh
traditional lawn traditional lawn care
lays down 90 million pounds of
pesticides a year yeah uh they don't
they're on a mission to change how we
care for our yards uh and you don't have
to choose between a beautiful yard now
and keeping your family out of harm's
way
okay because it's greener and it's
healthier okay sunday can help you grow
a beautiful grass a beautiful lawn
without the guesswork or the chemicals
their custom plans include fertilizer
and everything you need to easily care
for your lawn with ingredients like
seaweed iron and molasses you can feel
good with kids and pets being around it
you just go visit sunday.com uh you put
in your address and their lawn analysis
tool does the rest then they use soil
and climate data to create a personal
newsletter plan delivered to your door i
mean how do you not choose this company
it's easy to do you can attach this
ready to use pouch to your hose and then
you just spray it it takes less than 15
minutes and it gets all up in them roots
that's what it does sunday is offering
our listeners 20 off full season plants
start at just 129 and you can get 20 off
at checkout when you go visit get
sunday.com hey babe that's 20 off your
custom plan at get
sunday dot com slash hey babe sunday
used to be the lord's day now it's the
lawns day
you like that nice i just created that
take it if you guys want but the money
will go up on the next and read
all right it can be hard sometimes to
see the light at the end of the tunnel
when you have high interest debt and
sometimes it can be even harder to ask
for help that's where upstart comes in
upstart's model considers other factors
like your income employment and other
information provided in your loan
application to find out to find you a
smarter rate for your loan you could
check your rate in minutes for loans
between 1 000 to 50 000
without impacting your credit score you
can even receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
say goodbye to high interest credit card
debt is one of the first steps toward
financial independence i'm telling you
upstart powered personal loans can help
you pay down high interest debt all
online with simple and easy to
understand payment terms it's got over
1.8 million customers on their path to
financial freedom go down pimp uh but
yeah keep going down uh just the stuff
that's all yellow don't wait and check
your do not wait and check your rate
today at upstart.com hey babe that's
upstart.com hey babe to check your rate
today don't forget to use our url to let
them know we sent you loan amounts will
be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com
hey babe don't wait and check your rate
today at upstart.com hey babe that's
upstart.com hey babe to check your rate
today don't forget to use our url to let
them know we sent you loan amounts will
be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
providing your loan application go to
upstart.com hey vape um and and uh it's
wonderful a lot of good restaurants like
you'll have a lot of fun but savannah is
like when you're in that grid of like
the historical area right there's like
there's like uh
horse
drawn carriages and it looks it is
restored to the old i mean it's like so
it's unbelievable you walk around you
just you're gonna love it my hotel is in
the historic district yeah most likely
mine was at the top of it right at the
top and we'd walk so sev what hotel was
it did you stay if you were i don't
remember it was a nice one it was in a
park okay it was at a park which was
like it was at the top of the grid of
the historical area so literally i could
just i don't even need a two trolley i
literally just walk around and savannah
will find me don't find savannah give
savannah finds you that's how it works
and you can get on a little like
although they have the bike riders that
will take you up and down the streets
right on like the little like you see we
have in new york city yeah and you could
just throw that guy like you know some
cash and he'll take you up and down i
just was like i don't want to go
anywhere just to want to sightsee so you
stayed in a five six block radius and
loved it loved it that's all you need to
do it was so nice and it's by the water
food yeah and there's a couple of good
restaurants i'll tell you husk is one of
them i heard husk is is a very good
right i got reservations for huss and
then vic's on the river i got vixx i
don't know then alligator lounge is
another one babe do you remember where
we ate in savannah
yeah and then there's there's the one
that everyone goes to it's like the
historic glass with the pink lady oh the
pink lady house or whatever i tried to
make reservations i couldn't even get it
it's a tourist trap it was good
but it's like their oldest restaurant
it's an actual old home that you don't
need to kind of go there you don't know
yeah yeah that was good man yeah we
added a few different places and then um
yeah it's just it's you're gonna like it
and you know what's crazy it's set up
the way they set up the that town there
that historically was for war
so they every like every other block
there's this there's this town like in a
square like a a park an open park so
it's like laid out like like a picture
of grid right and then every other block
on the same block is a huge square like
a like a park and it's the same one all
on every side and all right because
that's where like they would like post
up to battle like they were telling us
the whole history wow but it looks
aesthetically it's gorgeous because it's
like beautiful old row houses and these
old victorian houses and then all of a
sudden there's this park and then again
in a park and again in a park and it's
like wow how did they and it's like no
that was actually there for like actual
battle strategy for the colonial war
civil war do we know
if you well look at it here we go here
we go savannah was gifted to president
lincoln during the civil war yeah uh
um what do we got we got uh savannah's
georgia's oldest city and first planned
city in the u.s catholicism was outlawed
when savannah was founded should i cover
up my catholic tattoos you might want to
the girl scouts were founded in savannah
on bringing cookies what more do you
need you can take your alcoholic drinks
to go in savannah i believe that's true
by the way today well when this episode
comes out it'll be
uh
in may i'm not gonna have a sip of out i
didn't have a sip of alcohol for 23 days
i said right now i didn't have well no i
i had one because i i drank puerto rico
when i went to puerto rico no i drank
puerto rico but i'm not going to have a
sip of alcohol from today until i go to
savannah the next time i drink is going
to go savannah because what i've been
doing are you going uh june 3rd
okay
because when i've been going what i've
been doing in my life and what i
realized it just makes life so much
better is i've been abstaining from
something and then when i finally do it
it makes it so much more sure worth it
so i feel like when i had a sip of uh
when i the the pina colada that i had
when i landed in puerto rico that i i
was saying
it hit me in a different way yeah where
the other people i was with who had been
drinking were like this pina colada is
okay i said this pina colada tastes like
it's it came from jesus's penis yeah
when you were when you were abs yeah i
know i know when you're abstaining in
the cold disrespect
let me say this respectfully and i'm not
even trying to be
if jesus yeah did in fact have semen i
would think because it is jesus the son
of man yeah his team it may have tasted
like a pina colada probably would taste
whatever and he wanted it to taste like
because it's beautiful and it's not i'm
not being disrespectful i'm just we're
adults here i know i understand yeah
you're pontificating yeah yeah i know
moon river brewing company did you go in
savannah i don't recall but if you
scroll up i think i just saw a picture
of the park that i state that i was at
i want to see the no just a point no
maybe something like that yeah oh my god
i see that marshall okay my i got to
bring my claritin
oh yeah
that's fine july august is when it gets
bad yeah but june's probably going to be
hot though but i'll bring some whatever
i'll wish woods yeah you wear shorts i
would bring shorts in june 100 right
yeah shorts in a tank yeah yeah why not
you want shorts out there or no uh i was
there in november so i didn't wear
shorts must have been perfect it was
perfect like 60 degrees the trees were
all like kind of like still up and still
just a little turning and everything and
it's such a quick flight from new york
it said like an hour and 15 minutes i
always said i want to go back i haven't
been back yet when oh you went in
november 2016 2024. yeah if he runs
again i'll go back just
just to be there
you're going to really love it you're
going to really love it um uh yeah i'm
excited to go who's got you're not
performing now no i have zero shows i'm
going with jazz just we said you know
what kids no actually the kids are not
going to go wow we just decided to go
see if he's watching them tt's gonna
watch the kids we just decided to go
cause we said you know what let's just
go why the hell not let's just go i vote
it's a place i've never been i've always
always always wanted to go i am gonna do
a show in charleston at the charleston
music hall in october november so i
figured i'll go back i'll you know
savannah so you go back to charleston
comedy
fig and then i heard there's another
place in charleston called hyman's
uh
i think that's the name of it i i i
think someone broke into that and i'm
not sure if they're around anymore
solute yeah
um so babe and then yeah so now listen i
haven't seen when i was in uh puerto
rico um
what were you doing were you just in new
york what were you doing yeah
i think i had covered
i was home for uh i think it was ten
calendar days
uh it was what opposite lives was to
like those ten days yeah delightfully
you had coveted bedridden i was in
puerto rico smashing coconuts
had to miss three shows because of it i
had a show and give your quinnip
quinnipiac winnipedia university of
course in connecticut yeah yeah well the
great lacrosse team yeah yeah yeah i had
a show there they had this big event for
the seniors called wake the giant
apparently i just found out about this
and i was supposed to i was super
psyched got covered and i had to skip
that and then the students got all upset
at me online they were like yeah you owe
us an apology are you serious yeah they
were like you should fully
yeah but i guess i didn't tell them that
immediately yeah what were you going to
do i mean you could have done it i
tested positive that day oh man so it
was like you weren't feeling well no and
then i plummeted yeah but then the next
weekend i was still testing positive
when i was supposed to be in louisville
in evansville so i had to kick those to
june
so i missed three shows i didn't do much
you were in the tropics yeah and that's
what i was basically doing i watched all
of severance
is severance a good show on apple tv
blow your balls okay but let me ask you
this because i it's funny that you said
that cause i was gonna watch sit down
and watch it yesterday apple tv and said
i want to watch it again i watched the
john gain john wayne daisy tapes on
netflix but
severance is it comparable to succession
is it the same you guys you guys have
touched on this we did we talked about
last time i told you to watch it i don't
know whenever we talked about the
difference
just tell me briefly because i didn't no
i mean i mean i don't know like this is
season one it was nine episodes it's
more of like a i don't know how to even
describe it it's like a sci-fi thriller
mystery
drama comedy watch
i i loved it i loved it and it ends it
ends on such a crazy note
now succession i think is like one of
the best shows ever ever made i can't
tell you about succession
written directed everything shot it's
it's just unbelievable i would say
severance i love it it's one it's one of
the it's probably the show i've gotten
most excited about since
succession
and i've even watched yellowstone and i
think i this gripped me even a little
bit more than that wow you got gripped
even more yeah wow because okay i love a
good mystery i love a good like you got
to figure it out
i um there was oh we haven't spoken
since i think one of the last times i
don't think we've done a podcast since i
bombed at bentley university with you um
i don't think so yeah i don't know i
don't know if we did we did a hockey
arena one of the last times i saw sal
was like back in february and i
him and i did a hockey uh arena at
bentley university and i bombed we all
bombed no no but i i mean i'm just much
as much
legitimately just as much it was i would
say you got off though and said it was
your worst bombing i've been doing stand
up i started stand up first time ever
hit the stage it was 2009
professionally like headlining since
about 2014.
let's say
i've done let's say just make it easy it
might even be more than this let's say
i've done a thousand
sets right
that was
the worst yeah i'm talking about number
one
worst set i've ever had for 30 minutes
absolute pin job science where i started
yelling to the children at belly
university i hope we get nuked right now
i hope you guys never see your families
again yeah you went i was yelling at
them and then they started laughing yeah
yeah yeah you you took a very uh you
took a very different stance than i did
on them i said you guys are going to
come back to your dorm rooms and i'm
going to be i'm going to be dead hanging
from one of your ceiling fans and they
didn't laugh
at that
it was weird when you started like
because you know usually you like start
calling it out and you start making fun
of it but then they're not laughing at
that well you know i'm on the side and
i'm watching it i heard him i'm cracking
up i'm crazy what happened why did they
not speak english no it was like it was
like it was hard it's like a 1500 kid
students that just were all
not laughing yeah they didn't
it was just very weird who goes to a
comedy show not to last well the kids
they don't know they don't even know but
how old are you
here's the thing 19 to 22. that's not
really true though because i do a lot of
colleges
and i would say if i'm gonna break down
all my colleges i would say fifty
percent of the shows are hot
25 percent of them students the show
you're saying
50 of the students are hot i mean
i think i told you one time about this
terrible joke i made while i was hosting
a talent competition out of college no
please tell us i think i told you that
there was the lit this
it was a mis it was it i just made the
wrong call i was up there riffing jokes
for three hours you know it's like
hosting an awards show it was like cs
it's got
talent yeah you just got to keep making
[ __ ] up there was someone with the last
name demeo
and she was a younger very attractive
girl she wore something very provocative
and then
this is three hours of students
competing and i'm riffing the whole time
and then she she came out and they the
judges told her what she got and she
walked off and the crowd applauded and i
just said wow i've never wanted to hold
demayo more in my life
did it bomb yeah it was like a groan
when the whole place crawled and i was
like i didn't mean it like i meant it
because the wordplay was so funny i
didn't really mean it like but you know
she looked she was a full adult yeah she
wasn't a child it wasn't like that she
was like 22 or whatever but
but i i i was it was a miscue on my part
i shouldn't have said that but i i think
you would have laughed if you would
[ __ ] die yeah and i
my buddy jay was on the side of the
stage and he was crying
and then like it just that comment
stayed with me for like the next hour on
stage it just was like you it was like
still with you now
[Laughter]
speaking of holding demayo teen with the
longest legs in the world reaches new
heights on only fancy yeah this teen has
the longest legs i wanted you to see
this look at her legs
those are it's it's it's insane she
looks like jack i mean no offense oh my
god
[Laughter]
she just walked past the threshold and i
had game of thrones
what was this one she has look the
ceilings in her house are through the
roof because that's the only way that
she has 30-foot ceilings it's jack
skellington-esque you know jack
skellington from nightlife before
christmas
classic wow look at those legs god bless
how do you buy pants
she grew up she consistently keeps
getting taller does she have a disease
she keeps getting a lot taller she just
keeps getting taller too oh my god she
just she's she's on the
she's on the volleyball team and she
just doesn't have to jump into high
school what does she have an only fans
for everyone has an only fans you can
have only fans in high school that's
absurd that's pedophilia
oh it depends on what you use
oh she's 19. okay but as all only fans
used to that's not what the only fans is
used for i mean what else you're going
to use only fans for when you say i've
been oh no
you don't have a book club unless you're
reading the book out of that
[Applause]
i know all the girls i know on it it's
not uh anything but she's clearly not
doing that so it's kind of nice it's
gonna be she's six foot ten and like no
i think it is 35 dollars a month and
what is she doing on it let's log in
uh
no i um i honestly have no i don't have
any information about only fans i know
that i know in culture people like oh
people go on and that's basically how
they make money doing it's almost like
webcam shows and [ __ ] like that or
putting a provocative little it's like
uber for your naked photos
how is it like uber because it's not
just a specialty niche profession
anymore it's been
like anyone can sign up and do it it's
so easy oh like everyone could drive
over anyone anyone can go and only i
thought you were like they're gonna
they're gonna deliver them to me
medallion pricing what is her only fans
about though yeah that is a good maybe
she's not sexual you can't have them
wrong what percentage of people do you
think that only fans are doing something
that's sexual i think a hundred percent
of them no
can't be
was it because that's not what it was
born out of right it's what it became
right um no i think that that time you
have an only fans is it almost like a
patreon yeah it's exactly what it is
which is coming can i get an only fence
you want to get one we'll make one for
you right now you want an only fans i
want why what what do i need to do if i
haven't only fans do i have to just do
web shows where i talk to people that or
i mean or but i think the ones who make
money who get a little freaky deaky you
gotta get a little freaky i think cash
me outside made a million dollars they
said 60 million yeah yeah 60 600 million
she made no no no no no she just bought
a six million dollar house over 50 over
50. she says that no she means she just
bought a six million house in cash all
right she published the bank statements
she published her bank statements that
says she has 50 million transferring
from from only fans
she's got to pay taxes on that while
florida shows up to pay the state tax oh
[ __ ] really yeah good for her wait why
would she post that
yeah 50 million bucks people were
claiming it was fake yeah she made 50
million on only fans
says she's always baby
she's over cash me outside references
she looks different too now did she get
she looks like she's not she's a child
anymore isn't she young though isn't she
very young not anymore i think she's
older i think she's a teenager
i don't think so yes a dude she's a
teenager i'm telling you right now
yeah she was like 13 on dr phil look she
published i can't i can't see 42 million
bucks up there
how many subscriptions is that
i don't i can't read that number what is
that that's a lot of money tips millions
16 000. oh 161 000 that's not millions
tips
messages
here's the gross i think or the net
the net is 52 million so oh because only
fans takes 10 percent yeah or whatever
it is
it's 120
so 50 they're taking 20 percent they
take that so they take 20 and she's got
to pay tax on that 42. no right so she's
but she's in florida she's 19. she's 19
you're right yeah
there you go damn that is good for her
wait so it's not even so she didn't even
make that off of her music she said and
she tweeted the
caption and she said go cry about it
[ __ ] why even why even do music anymore
so she made more
than
99.9 percent of people on this planet by
just
just charging to talk to her on the
computer you don't even talk to her you
just look at her naked photos and like
it she's posting naked photos i'm i
haven't been on her account no if she
was posting naked photos
they'd be out because someone will just
take a picture with their family you go
on reddit and you just type in their
name leaked photos no no but
it'd be everywhere right because let's
say she had a naked photo and i was the
person on wouldn't i could i just take a
picture of my screen it just watermarked
her only fans you could illegally
how would those not be up everywhere i
could pirate jokers
right but i'm saying i don't think she
did it because you could type her name
in right now nude and it would come up
immediately there's no way someone with
that status she has that kind of 50
million status she's in that demand she
posts something with her
naked that's going to be online so she's
not even she's making that money not
even getting i think she probably just
shows like maybe a nipple or something i
don't know yeah it's stuff like that
where she's
i guess she's just um
you know walking around and wait so this
is just out there nicotine alternatives
you love them i love it if we're talking
nikki all turns we're talking lucy look
we're all adults here and i know some of
us choose to use nicotine to relax focus
or just unwind after a long day lucy is
a modern oral nicotine company that
makes nicotine gum lozenges and pouches
for adults who are looking for the best
most responsible way to consume the
nicotine it's a new year well i mean it
has been why not start it out with
switching the new nicotine product that
you can feel better about that's what it
is baby if you enjoy if you enjoy using
nicotine you should definitely check out
lucy's products at lucy dot co that's
lucy.co and use promo code babe b-a-b at
checkout i'm telling you if you are
interested in a better way to use
nicotine visit
lucy.co and be sure to use that promo
code babe b-a-b-e i'm telling you they
are the best at oral products no one's
going to give you better oral than lucy
that's right warning this product
contains nicotine nicotine is addictive
chemical listen your aunt is using you
you want your aunt to use lucy as
opposed to smoking yeah then you put
that you you take that lucy they sent me
samples now i'm gonna give it to my aunt
you i'll open up her i'll i'll hold her
mouth open you throw it in yeah look at
the seagull yeah lucy.co promo code hey
babe
baby you want to talk about a new way to
bank that's what i want to talk about
let's talk about novo fortune favors the
bold the strong the brave the beautiful
for your business to break out of
anything holding you back you need
business checking as brave as you are as
brave as your mama was whoa introducing
novo business checking novo is
powerfully as powerful as your mama was
yes is is powerfully simple business
checking that's all it is instead of a
one-size-fits-all approach novo knows
that there's all different shapes and
sizes out there so it customize is
itself to your business to save you time
and free up cash flow with seamless
integrations to stripe shopify
quickbooks online and more all that and
unlike traditional banking models novo
has no minimum balances much like your
mama mom no transaction limits and no
hidden fees sign up for novo for free
and join the community of over 150 000
fearless small businesses who have found
the customizable business checking
solution that admires their brave
sign up for your free business checking
account right now at
[Music]
o
novo.com
hey babe plus hey babe listeners get
access to over 5
000 bucks in perks and discounts go to
n-o-v-o
dot c-o that's n-o-v-o dot co slash hey
babe to sign up for free
novo dot co slash hey babe novo platform
inc is a fintech
not a bank
like your mama banking services provided
by middlesex federal savings fa member
fdic terms and conditions apply yeah
yeah it's leaked oh it is yeah i guess
she just shows her bot yeah
nude only fans leaked and sexy photos
leaked
yeah oh but that's what she does oh she
just was she was just [ __ ]
on dr phil at like 15.
only fans though as a business whoever
created is a pretty genius idea because
they said everyone's sexting and why not
pay for a service where you can be
sexted by someone that you are a fan of
but you know is that what you do
you know it's dangerous sex people that
she doesn't know well
basically of saying like if you tip her
like you tip her and she'll send you a
message of uh you know without i don't
know what i've actually seen people do
like almost cameos while they're like
doing stuff to themselves to you if you
can't only fit i think you could do sex
videos too like it's a whole wild world
up there dude our children are coming
into a [ __ ] yeah that's what a nuke
might be a good can you imagine that
she's she's worth 50 40 million dollars
it's great 20 minutes
she's worth tens and tens of millions of
dollars
essentially let's be honest she went on
dr phil that's how she got her name out
there
kudos to her for managing
that springboarding off that and
managing it well i heard the music the
music's not for me but apparently she's
doing great with the music but could you
imagine that she could make that kind of
she's making more than ceos
of major companies which they don't
deserve that either she's making more
than professional ball players i know
that's
literally just doing something out of
our house that probably doesn't even
take that long but what's scary is like
all right she's doing great but the
coolest kid in high school right now
launches one and then all the high
school boys you know what i mean like
there's no real
thing stopping these kids from just
joining it you have to be 18 i'd imagine
oh yeah you never lied yeah it's true
yeah i'm i gotta imagine they have a
stringent
policy to check i'm sure it says a birth
date
you think so of course there would be so
many losses they would get shut down
they would get shut down if they weren't
taking the right steps to make sure
that's not going to be uh you know
like young underage kids they'd get shut
down in a heart but how how can you put
like they probably make you upload all
your jobs or something like that yeah i
i think so
children are recently selling explicit
content only fans so
shut down by the new york post
immediately it's what just happened um
yeah wow yeah this is a crazy it's a sad
world wow kid-sized singer's 12 years
old
jesus what so how do they not get shut
down immediately
what is only coco onlyfans.com i mean
that show euphoria is just children's
only fans for hbo i will watch it i i
watched one season i said i can't do
this i don't want to hear it it feels
weird i heard it was a good show but i i
i i think it's going to upset me because
i have you know i have young family
members that's why we stopped watching
should i sign in with the taste buds
twitter
um so what is it is it just like you
have just how do you find people you
just search for them
all right let's see this whole thing's
got to get shut down dick i mean
no it's like uber you don't you won't
find you by your real name you find them
by an at
and then the girls all have the at in
their and there's girls i'm like you
know they they want to go on a date with
me and then i click on their profile and
it's an only fan's link on the top
really and then it becomes like well
isn't everyone's
wife gonna have an only fans in her past
wow yeah
yeah but but i i wonder like once you
shut it down it's shut down it's not
accessible on the internet
right so it's like you shut down your
account you take down all those videos
but her leak stuff's up
but she doesn't give a [ __ ] she's making
40 million dollars she's 19 years old
what about the girl who made what about
the girl who's a middle who makes 450 a
month right yeah but no one's finding
her
i mean but you have she shuts that down
she has the life ahead of her she's not
uh one year you make 40. literally you
make she's 19 you made 40 million
dollars let's say netted let's say she
netted 30 after taxes what do you need
to do anything for again i mean go live
your life do it everyone but as far as
money goes you're good it's insane you
don't need any more money the amount
that she has made versus the work that
she has put in not saying she doesn't
work hard now she doesn't hustle now
she's not really trying to make it in
the music i'm not saying that now but
give me i mean no she
she wasn't this until a year or two ago
no and now she's worth
40 million dollars
that's insane yep that's insane dude so
do we do an online instead of a patreon
for hey
where we do hey but we'll do a butt
naked
would you do that
uh who was going to give us 40 mil would
you do a year of hay bay butt naked only
on only fans for 40 at the end we get 40
million dollars but we have butt naked
no pillows
oh
we could keep yeah well if you do it
once it's the same as doing 100 every
every episode what the hell is the
difference
got 40 million dollars
but we're butt naked on this couch this
is everything same we're buttoning and
we're going to make it too yeah you
would do it
he got 40 mil at the end
yes we got then we got to split it but
we get two we got to pay taxes no let's
say we're netting 20 each we're dead
we're netting 20 each that's i that
would be i'd have to consider that okay
i mean right you know right now i'm safe
in the comments money you want us to do
it i'm saving money i'm doing it on the
up and up right now
yeah
that's a tough one that's a tough one
because then because then we you know
you get what does he have what is t ty
guys
7.69 million on only fans
what yep
a lot of a lot of people are making real
money on this mia khalifa i understand
she's appointed i don't know what how do
they know what these people make though
it's all public like patreon yeah it's
like so then why did she have to prove
her 42 million because oh good point
people really didn't believe her yes i
don't know it's interesting mia khalifa
who's a porn star is on only fans when
you can just watch her that's why she's
only for free that's why she's only not
in six mil yeah only six mil gets messy
guys it just gets weird i will i mean
come on who's the number one only fans
um is she one number one bad baby this
might be an older list blac chyna got it
blac chyna's 20 million but that's less
than bad baby now so now what does blac
chyna do but she doesn't do anything she
dated a kardashian oh rob kardashian
yeah is she is she in uh
are she's a rapper
right
i thought she was just a stripper
formerly i'm not sure
yeah that's what i'm saying also you're
not gonna get shunned if you haven't
only fans if that's what you own if you
own it it's just the people that
that think that that's not a i mean look
i mean you gotta you gotta give props to
these people like props it's just crazy
though that
it's just this is this is blowing my
mind this is blowing it's like imagine
like our parents like my dad worked for
20 30 40 years and retired and
of hard labor and doesn't have a
fraction of a fraction of a fraction of
what
the bad baby made in in one day
it's just you know i was just saying
like the new one percentage is people
hot enough for other people to want to
pay for their nudes
yeah the like the mansions that this is
because normally it was like all right
you're going to become an influencer on
instagram but that that can't net you
anywhere near this kind of money no way
i wonder if i should pay
somebody like a blac chyna to put you
sponsor them
no or like i pay and i ask them to put
the trailer to my netflix special
especially she on their only fans that's
funny would that be good let's do it
yeah why not they're watching it in the
back i thought you were like i wonder if
i should just hire someone and pay them
like you you're an agent for only fans
actually it's not a bad idea well what
can they just do with themselves though
at that point you're a pimp dude
[Laughter]
not a homeless pimp though
could be depends on who your clients are
only fans explained what you need to
know okay
not safe what is nsfw not safe for
workplaces not safe for work videos and
photos to their accounts which are
protected by a paywall to gain access to
the content and eventual individual must
pay a monthly subscription that ranges
anywhere from 499 to 50 five bucks to
fifty bucks
what's she charging uh what's her name i
would say bad baby's gotta be 50 bucks
right like she's getting it's got to be
fitty um
so crazy man yeah it's not for me
well i have to deal with it more than
you got i mean if you're younger i'm
gonna have to date someone who has an
only fans and like
you know you just watch videos of them
randomly having sex so sad that kane
kane tanaka could have an only fans i
know [ __ ] god she would have made
everything she would have made billions
only who would who would who could make
if who started and only fans what person
starting and only fans would make more
money than bad baby like you think if
trump had only fans he'd make that
i honestly i i i would i would pay to
see that yeah
yeah oh my god i'm afraid is this the
tall woman oh my god what the hell is
that yeah people see do all types of oh
wow oh she's doing it whoa whoa whoa
huge [ __ ] and she's stabbing it
okay what
i don't know i think she's she's doing
some type of erotica
with um stabbing you i put on the worst
of only fans montage okay worst of only
fans montage so
see i think
oh
god
what just happened that thing came out
of nowhere wow
oh
what there you go is that real yeah this
is all real yeah you can't show any of
this no no i'm not showing this is just
your reactions here is that real yeah
this woman is uh does she know what's
going on or no heavy set girl playing
the woman to the right doesn't know
what's going on
she has no idea that woman's right there
is that a crime i think so uh yeah it
seems like she's squirting and rubbing
her vagina off with her foot on the
chair on the armchair of a
hundred-year-old woman who looks senile
oh my god
okay
now there's a woman taped up moaning on
the floor this is weird it's really
weird man
just getting tied up
that stuff's humiliating this is like
how do you that's something you can't
walk away from
people identify that woman that just did
that with that old woman yeah and it's
also like stuff like that it's like hey
to each their own whatever gets you off
but it's also like there's a change
there's a deep insecurity there with
these it's like oh there's you're going
to degrade yourself like that to make
money oh i mean start a podcast right
have some decency
we're doing a podcast you don't look
like foolish yeah exactly i mean you
have to delete some tweets and stuff but
you know oh my god
i'm shocked at what you just showed me
that was a lot yeah i've been seeing
weird things with only fans that worry
me
interesting well do you think now we're
getting to the point where like elon
musk just took over twitter all these
only fan things like do you think it's
going to get to a point where society is
going to step in and be like all right
this is illegal now like you can't do
this anymore or do you think it just
gets worse from here
that's a really good question thank you
uh well this has been hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey baby